[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: This is I/O
Live, and I'm Timothy Jordan.
And I'm standing here
with Hannah Beachler
who is a production designer.
You may know her
from "Black Panther".
HANNAH BEACHLER: Hello.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
How are you today?
HANNAH BEACHLER: I've got
to give it one of these.
Great.
I'm doing great.
I'm so happy to be here.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Me too.
We're really glad that you came
here to talk about your work
and to talk about
diversity and inclusion
and how that's affected by
representation in media.
HANNAH BEACHLER: Absolutely.
I mean, I think a
big important part
of that is if you don't
see it, you can't be it.
And so putting those things into
our narrative work in films,
which everybody finds the
time to go see a good movie,
as noted by "Infinity War",
and to represent a huge portion
of the population in that way.
I think when people see it,
they realize, I can do that.
I can have those
same goals in life
because it's not going
to be impossible.
And I think that that's
such a huge important part
of my work, in my body of work,
over the last three years.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah, one of
the things I think about a lot
is that I was really
lucky growing up
wanting to be an engineer
and seeing lots of engineers
that looked like me.
And that was inspiring, and I
really want that for everyone.
HANNAH BEACHLER: Absolutely.
I mean, I think inspiring
the next generation
of young scientists
who are female,
young kids of color who
see a world where they have
a sense of pride, where they
have a sense of reaching
back and seeing their
tradition, and their culture,
and their ancestors, and
all those things even
being a part of their future.
And I think walking away with
a huge sense of themselves
that they otherwise may not
know or have had privy to.
So it's lifting spirits
that's so important when
it comes to representation.
It's not only about getting
into certain fields.
It's about who we're raising
in the world for the future.
Because I know I'm going to
be relying on my young child
to take care of me, and I
want him to know some things.
So it's always on my
mind, and it's something
that I think I'm now more than
ever driven to do and include
as part of my design aesthetic.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah, it's
almost like if you can see it,
you can be it.
HANNAH BEACHLER: Absolutely.
And I've been watching.
You know, I watch all
the videos on Twitter.
People will send me
stuff of teachers
teaching about the sort
of things that we did--
I did a deep dive, but it
was sort of a lighter dive
into the technology
in "Black Panther"
and the science in
"Black Panther".
And teachers are
coming up with a way
to teach the class
using "Black Panther"
as an example of our vibranium
and our sound science
that we used in the movie.
And to see that become a
part of a curriculum and kids
getting excited about it
because they see themselves
and yeah, I can do this, is--
I mean, you can't ask
for anything more.
I've always thought, what can
I do to better the world as one
individual?
And I didn't really know ever
what that was until, I think,
after "Black Panther" and I
saw the response of young kids.
And it was all about
the representation.
And so that does
become a design choice.
And it's something that
I think that I'm just
going to do now forever.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Let's talk
about that a little bit more
because you're on
record as saying
that, when you were
working on "Black Panther",
you were just focusing
on it being good.
HANNAH BEACHLER: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Right?
But then afterwards,
looking back
on how big a deal this
is for how many people,
how has your
perspective changed?
HANNAH BEACHLER: I mean, hugely.
Because it was just
you're kind of in it
and you can't, like
you were saying,
see the forest or the trees.
So you're just wanting to make
sure it's good and it's right
and that people are going
to be happy and proud
and that you did
the right thing,
you made the right choices.
Because at the
end of the day, it
was a lot of responsibility
in some aspects.
And then after, when
I saw it, I was like--
I mean, my eyes were-- because
I did a little bit of the VFX.
I was there for a
little bit, but I
didn't see the final edit.
I saw one of the cuts.
So when I was there in the
theater with everybody else,
I was blown away.
I was like, this is insane.
I can't believe I did this.
And seeing the responses,
it's just on another level.
It's just-- you know, it's
really hard to put into words
or articulate in a way
that others can understand
because it really is--
it made me speechless,
in a sense.
There hasn't been
the words made yet
to describe what that's like.
But it was certainly always
about making a good movie
with a great story.
And hopefully, everything
else sort of fell in line.
And then we had other great
filmmakers, Ruth Carter,
who is a Oscar-nominated
costume designer, who
I worked with really intensively
to make sure that what
we did matched up, you know?
Because a lot of what
she did in the foreground
on the characters defined
who they were on screen,
so that also gave back
to the representation
of powerful women who had
their own agency about them
and could make
their own decisions
and stand up for themselves
and could think quick
on their feet.
That's a whole other
sense of representation
in a social aspect
for young kids,
young girls, and the
men who treated them
on this equal playing field.
There was no, like oh, we need
to make it easy for the girls.
You saw the door fight.
You saw the king treat
them as if they were--
when they were the most
powerful guards in Wakanda.
So it's all of those
things mixed together.
Then, you talk about the
technology on top of that.
You're giving a new generation,
old generation, my generation,
a whole other narrative
than the one that we've
sort of heard for the last
how many ever decades.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Let's
talk a little bit more
about the technology, but not
go away from the human aspects
that you're talking about.
I think one of things that has
always really interested me
in technology is not how to
make tech just better on its own
and then teach
people how to use it,
but rather, teach technology
how to be better for people.
HANNAH BEACHLER: Absolutely.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And I
think that you've really
captured in this film an
intersection with culture,
and people, and technology.
How did you approach that?
HANNAH BEACHLER:
That's heavy, man.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, very carefully.
Because it's really trying
to understand community, what
the needs of community
are, and then how do
we envelope the technology,
just what you said.
And I know, for Ryan,
community was really important.
And I talked to
a lot of experts.
It wasn't just me sort
of coming up with things.
I talked to a lot of people who
really knew, nanotechnologists,
neuroscientists, archaeologists,
geologists, geographers,
on a daily basis to understand
how to fold that in.
And I think that one of the
biggest things that I did was I
tried to find--
a lot of the tech was
based on biomimetics--
so I tried to find in nature
and in different cultures what
the use of something was and
then the evolution of it.
Because at the
end of the day, it
is all about the evolution
of it, how we are in society
and how we are advancing
technologically.
So it was me relating
these things back
in a way that represented
what they are really used for
and how they would
have evolved over time.
And I think technologically,
often times, it
is the thing for
the thing's sake
and not, here is
something that has
been such a big
part of a tradition
of any nationality, any
ethnicity, any culture
or religion.
And this is how it becomes
useful in a futuristic
and an advanced way.
If that means
technology, then that's
the way that it would be.
So that's sort of how I
strung those together.
And then pulling from
nature, that was a huge one.
And thereby, keeping
everything organic, in a sense.
So it becomes not
such a scary thing,
but a very organic thing.
Because we're so used to seeing
certain things in nature--
patterns, shapes, geometry.
All of these things--
math, science-- it's
all around us constantly.
So it was really
easy, at some point,
to start just looking
just into nature.
Because it is science.
It is technology.
You know what I mean?
The way everything works.
So looking beyond the
hardware and the finish
of the hardware of it and into
the organic nature of it all.
That's a little dive
into how it went.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It must have
been a very full 14 months
working on this film.
HANNAH BEACHLER: Beyond.
We were on three continents.
We were in two states.
And I had a team,
at any given moment,
that were 500 strong,
just in my department.
So we went 14 months,
and we went hard
as we could go for 14
months to get this done.
My whole team put every
last inch of themselves.
So it was a beautiful thing
because we represented
the diaspora, just our crew.
So it was a micro
version of the macro
that we were
building in Wakanda.
I lived that every single
day for a little over a year.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
I want to ask you
about what's next,
but it doesn't have to
be specific projects.
But it's like, where do you
go from here with everything
that you've talked about, like
the production design itself,
but the bigger themes and
ideas that you're working on?
HANNAH BEACHLER: You
know, challenging myself,
I think, to try to
continue to do things that
are out of my comfort zone.
Something I learned
from Ryan Coogler,
who has taken me from
"Fruitvale Station"
to a boxing movie,
"Creed", to a comic book
movie, "Black Panther".
I want to continue
the trend on my own
and not just be in a place
that I feel comfortable.
My next project with
Melina Matsoukas, who
was a director for "Insecure"--
I'm just working on the
pilot for "Why the Last Man",
which is a graphic novel.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yes.
I've read the entire series.
HANNAH BEACHLER: OK.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So good.
[LAUGHTER]
HANNAH BEACHLER: So I'm going
to be designing the pilot.
We're working on
that, currently.
I can't really say
much more than that,
but it's super exciting.
The script is phenomenal.
And our approach to
it is going to be,
I think, something really cool.
So I'm really super
excited about that.
Worked with Beyonce again.
That's all I can say about that.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Woo!
[LAUGHTER]
HANNAH BEACHLER: And
the future is wide open.
And if the Denis
Villeneuve is listening,
I'd love to do "Doom".
[LAUGHTER]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yes.
HANNAH BEACHLER: I throw
that out every opportunity
I can get.
Denis?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
Hannah, thank you so much
for joining me and sharing
your story and all
the work that you do.
HANNAH BEACHLER:
Thank you so much.
It's super exciting.
I'm so happy to be
here, and I think
I'm going to learn
something today too.
So it's all about soaking
in all this greatness.
So fabulous.
Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank you.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is I/O Live.
[MUSIC PLAYING]